okay all right good morning tom Jason
are you doing there Dave
crystal Tommy good morning Jake
how are ya pretty good Kenny yeah yeah I
you know so early in the morning I'm
sorry to be the bearer of bad news but
you know how I was supposed to work late
tonight
mmm well I got to run this errand for
mr. Mahina and he says that you're gonna
have to cover for me so there it is
I don't need I'm sorry drop the ax hmm
again yeah oh you know what just
remembered mr. Mahina also almost lit my
mind wants us to change parking spaces
what yeah me personally I enjoy the
nine-minute walk but he said that we
have to do it believe it I hate it as
much as you do what do you do nothing
you can do mr. Mahina said it Mahina
this whole situation has been Mahina
nice it just seems a little confusing to
me as to why mr. Mahina would give a
[ __ ] where we park how's that I mean why
would he care where we I don't know the
answer to that question I mean that's
what he said hey you know what I know
you're busy but she was crazy in there I
mean that was tense yeah you know what's
really crazy though
I've been working here for about a year
and I've never even seen mr. Mahina well
see that's that's an easy one to answer
that's because he comes in before you
come into work and he's still working
when you leave that's what makes it mr.
Mahina you know come on we're talking
about mr. Mahina here right
Pervis says you know I bet the
hard-working boss would love to meet a
hard-working employee you know shares
the same values so I'm gonna go ahead
and just introduce myself no no you
can't go into some heinous room are you
crazy no one except me is allowed to go
in there mr. Mahina is busy okay fine
you made your point clear man thank you
very much take
come on man what question my existence
will have the end-of-the-year report to
you about ten
you